i wasn't born in hawaii i was born in
san francisco but i did a lot of my
growing up there so yeah so it was it
was amazing i don't know i don't think
no tell me
what's more you say for years i've
always said well when we were there you
gave me a big speech like this is my
land
trick-or-treat why are you dressed like
that because it's my costume all you
gotta do is go to the costume store and
say make me look stupid
don't stand like that that's the problem
that's not how i said it didn't stand
like that
when we were there and he gave me a very
like spiritual speech about how it all
started
this is a cliff where i was born and my
mother
[Laughter]
this is the problem
you want some candies oh you want the
king size candy yeah no you don't get
that at all here's what you get it's
bite-sized tiny mini like you i don't
want that put this in your fanny pack
maybe next year you don't try to save
money on your decorations around here
hey kids dwayne and rock johnson is
giving out raisins and pennies this
sucks okay okay stupid house okay
okay you have a lot of projects around
it that you could have chosen you picked
this one why ah
good you got it
come in
and then
uh
also
come on chemistry
he give me that
uh
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
i mean outside of the the spiritual
grounds that you took me to and i swear
you even sung a song you were like
i don't like to share that with you
we'll talk about it later
like
i smell a lot of marvel [ __ ] up in
here wait a second
i smell it now you smell it now i smell
it now smell all those marvel [ __ ]
now
[Applause]
that makes it worse though big time
snore
so coming out now okay well you fart in
your sleep how about that well that's a
different situation he farts in his
sleep gas x it's uh not my best friend
whatever he sleeps with the diaper he's
a person all right these are personal
problems that nobody needs to know chris
evans
captain america superman and batman will
slap you right back into the fantastic
four you ain't
we will kick your ass right back to
asgard that's right that's right i
kicked your ass out your guard you
stinky [ __ ] yeah go i got you which of
your co-stars would you like to switch
with
because i don't know what it's like to
be stupid
i
i want to be stupid
just for a day
all right what we got here what we got
here okay we got all the children's shop
we got a chat right here okay hey
boss man
hey make sure you give me a thing all
right
intelligent central intelligence
shooting my
out i'm shooting my videos
he shoot his video
[ __ ] your video
my fans will beat the [ __ ] out your fans
the [ __ ] your fans what uh what what
what type of uh what type of person
were you in school ladies man
nerd which one class clown i was glass
clown that's a class count back in high
school the class clown because i was the
one i was just making everybody laugh i
was the one who i would throw my voice
i would throw my voice like hey he did
the thing and then they get
[Laughter]
i like your movies more okay oh come on
man don't make me flash up here
i mean some of our favorites was the uh
the big short wait that wait what no no
it's not my hip-hop hobbit that was good
wait that's not that's not my movie
movie you did that
what the [ __ ] are you talking about i
never did that i'm kevin hart right
right in high school okay um yeah hey
hey
hey everybody hey
hey girl
hey girl
hey no
she ain't hearing me she ain't hear me
hey what's up money
come on
come on
hey miss johnson yeah
i'm gonna do good on that test
i don't know what it was like working
with the uh
[Laughter]
oh he was great rock was great he did
that thing yo
i don't know why i blink right now but
that's what he i can't even do it
i can't even do it don't forget you got
to say the question so they know what
you're talking about what do you say
like that for like why are you angry all
right you forget all the time
people know what you're doing did he not
take his medicine i'm on edge baby
i ain't had my coffee
sensitive times everybody
[Music]
the jumanji league of superheroes and
dwayne you were black adam karen was
nebula and jack was nacho libre who
would kevin be
pete
he'd be honky pete
what would his superpowers be i'd be
black adam look at a honky pete
central intelligent promo let me finish
my video why are you yelling like this i
just started mine let me finish well i
got my videos important too give me a
second and then while doing what we do
probably gonna tell you something man
i'm getting tired of this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
in your videos
hey don't you know what i'm man
yeah people can can bite that
five million people with the [ __ ] out of
you
all right so basically you better watch
your [ __ ] mouth right now how do you
cuss so much [ __ ] have some respect for
the women here sorry ladies
and gentlemen you got a five mouth okay
i'm saying my fans don't need to hear
that because we're better than your
people let me talk to you you're right
here's what your fans need to hear
amazing people [ __ ] off okay i'm gonna
stop it
all right look sometimes
well often times things get intense here
in the iron paradise but
we ain't playing tiddlywinks and we
ain't reciting nursery rhymes
all right you get lumped up every once
in a while and things happen
that's good
that's real good back to work what up
world
i just got done doing session number two
in the gym
sometimes when you clinging and banging
[ __ ] happens
wait get to getting thrown
and sometimes
you wake up with a little knot
hey dwayne
you ain't the only one getting hit in
the head
with 45 pound dumbbells
and 45 pound plates
cause i am too
hard work
granted i'm a little dizzy
might have a concussion
but then ain't got a [ __ ] thing
to do with my motive
i'm be honest i ain't feeling too good
all right here we go wait we should
thank the people that's too right now
right hey real quick before we start
this record-breaking uh internet stream
event
we didn't give it a title it's it's it's
it's it's a record-breaking yeah
internet stream yes historic event
moment yes historic event moment
we're with the rock and kevin no we're
kevin hart
in
the pebble
no oh don't laugh at that
dwayne johnson and
it is kevin the hitman heart
and the bald guy
yes yes it is the rock up in this [ __ ]
and chocolate
hey if you if you just tuned into this
live stream we got kevin mother [ __ ]
heart
in
him
that's true that's true and for the
world who's tuning in because this is
going to be the biggest live stream ever
we got the rock in the [ __ ]
house we
got kevin long faced little butt lou aka
my shoes are red and he's on fire
because he walks real fast and his
shoulders are broad and he's got good
skin and he's the people person
and we got the [ __ ]